[Music]
want to fly abroad this year
don't even bother between the lateral
flow tests and the pcr tests
the mask guidance and the mansion of
paperwork flying is pretty impractical
these days
spectator columnist lionel schreiber has
managed to make it to new york
but wrote about the hellish experience
in this week's issue she joins me now
lionel in your column this week you said
that you've been surprised as you
suddenly found yourself agreeing with
theresa may
what's going on there i actually agree
with her for once
and uh you know it was a relief because
i've been so mean about her
i've screamed so many things at the tv
um
when she's speaking and it was
it was simply delightful to hear her
talking such common sense
you know she's very concerned about the
aviation industry
and the importance of a viable one
in in an island nation uh
she has a sensible attitude toward covid
she takes the government
seriously when it says that
we need to learn to live with covid
because it's
not ever going to get back down to zero
again
and if we keep
secretly pursuing a zero covet strategy
we will never be able to travel abroad
again
and is that really the kind of life we
want and i
i second that you know we we
do down airplanes all the time because
of concern
over climate change and i thought it was
important we finally
stick up for them i believe that
uh especially international air travel
is one of the most marvelous things
about being alive today and i don't want
to see it go away
now you're joining us from new york um
can you talk us through what your
experience is like i'm flying at the
moment because a lot of people have been
put off it entirely but
it's fair to say there are a lot more
hurdles than before
well they're right to be put off it and
furthermore the
uh the experience of flying right now
out of out of the country especially
out of the uk is a political one
in fact my biggest problem is that i
become a danger to myself
because this whole situation enrages me
so much
then i'm likely to get myself into
trouble um
you know we all know you have to get a
test
before flying i could live with that if
they took the results seriously
um okay fine i booked my lateral flow
test
with some difficulty because these
things are never simple
you know anything online is horribly
complicated
but i i i managed uh with a
great deal of self congratulations and i
went to the wrong testing center first
and then we
practically ran to the one on the fifth
floor terminal two
to make sure we got to our 410
appointment
um the experience was one of
relative efficiency given the
inefficiency of the entire business
but you know if you believe that the
tests are accurate
and therefore you have an entire load of
passengers who
are not infected with covid19
why do we have to wear masks you know
and that's even assuming that they work
which of course
they don't so that pantomime is
exasperating
and that's one of the reasons that air
rage
incidents especially in the united
states are going through the roof
and uh in my column i called attention
to
an incident that went viral last month
in which a poor flight attendant was
uh not only bloodied but lost two teeth
now the debate in uk government is
ultimately pushing towards harder border
restrictions
than any easing no no country's added to
the green list on the latest update
few expect there to be next time and i
think there seems to be this argument
developing
that actually tighter borders
particularly to countries like new
zealand and australia means greater
domestic freedoms it's what several
cabinet ministers are pushing
um do you think perhaps they do have a
point and
maybe traveling is just something that
is nice
uh that's what some would say but
ultimately domestic freedoms are gonna
count first
okay that's a very peculiar definition
of domestic freedom
not you know freedom not to be able to
leave your own country
that is more reminiscent of eastern
europe before the
fall of the iron curtain it's one of the
things that we used to feel sorry for
them about
um more than anything that they weren't
allowed to leave their own country
so i don't call that freedom and
furthermore
you know just as in if we believe the
tests work we shouldn't have to wear
masks on airplanes if we believe the
vaccines
work we should be able to fly wherever
we want
and come back home and not lock the door
behind us for 10 days
and we have not the
uk has not given the vaccinated
any more freedom any more rights
than the unvaccinated uh that is
demotivating
to get vaccinated but most of all it
casts
doubt on whether the government really
has faith in in its signature
program i mean we go to all this trouble
and expense
to vaccinate increasingly the better
part of the
adult population and yet you know
we're still cowering in fear and can't
go anywhere
uh there is no excuse for making me take
a test
at all to get on the plane there is no
excuse for making me quarantine when i
get home
and there's no excuse for making me get
these expensive pcr tests
um when when i arrived back in london uh
i am double vaccinated uh i got my
second jab
six weeks ago i'm as safe as houses
i'm as safe as it's going to get and if
i'm not safe
then then we're in this hell forever
now finally i just wanted to mention
your new book
should we say or should we go which
talks about confronting death and we
have a piece in this week's magazine by
ann wilson
which looks at perhaps how our attitudes
towards mortality has changed in the
past year and a half of the pandemic
do you think that people are now i
suppose more
focused or you could say sensitive about
deaths the idea of death has become
something that
should be eradicated around something
that perhaps we just have to accept
well i think the whole covert period has
heightened awareness of aging and
mortality
um and maybe in in the wrong direction
it's made people
more fearful uh more risk averse
and i i wish it were working the other
direction
um if there's any lesson in
my new novel which i hope is mostly just
exercise and share entertainment um
then it's that we need to be more
intentioned
in relation to the end of our life
and to apply the same kind of intention
to
our old age and inevitable death
as we do to the other parts of our our
lives i mean we plan
we plan to be uh
whatever when we grow up uh we
make decisions about marriage and family
you know we have a sense of direction
it's often subverted
but we don't want to we just don't want
to think about
the the last bit and
the the pandemic has forced us to
to think a little more about the the
last bit because it's been up in our
face in
broadcast newscasting and i
to agree if if we if we apply that
greater awareness in a positive way
that's that's not a bad thing
if we instead just become more and more
terrified uh well that's just
that's just a formula for not just
living and then dying but not
living at all
[Music]
you